what's up everyone welcome to the cinema
center at marble at Tiff 2023 I have the
pleasure of sitting with the team behind
unicorns huge huge huge congratulations
on your movie I mean it sincerely I
adored it thank you thank you so much
all right I'm gonna toss this duty to
one of you I'm sure you're doing this a
lot right now but our audience won't
know what unicorns is about just yet so
can someone give me a brief synopsis of
the film okay so uh unicorns
um is a cross-cultural romance about a
single father from Essex who's a
mechanic and he unexpectedly falls in
love with a British Indian drag queen
you were prepared for that I was gonna
say that's the hardest question I'm
asking the entire interview but you were
ready to go I get paid I get paid a
little bit more for that yeah
most impressive you deserve all that
extra money
um so you write the script and then you
decide that you don't want to direct
yourself you want a co-director what was
it about the material that made you
think that was best for it and then what
was it about Sally that made you think
that she was the perfect partner for
this well unfortunately Sally and I are
Partners in real life
um so fun fact
creation today so we any project I do I
have to tell her about it so so
um unicorns um for seven years was a
child in our house so it was something
that I watched James develop and as he
was working on different drafts of the
script
um you know it was a film then it was a
TV series and then it went back to a
film and I always thought it was best as
a film and so when he turned it back to
a film I said you know
at the time swimmers this other movie I
was working on had fallen apart in the
pandemic and um it was before Netflix
had come on board and we didn't know if
it was going to happen and I was
suddenly free and I said I think I'd be
interested in directing unicorns and so
that's when it first started as a
conversation is there anything you can
share about why you thought the story
was best served in the feature film
format rather than a series I think it's
because I mainly think in terms of films
it's not that I um have anything against
TV and I've worked a little bit in TV
but I think that the form of a film is
more conducive to a story
um that isn't you know you have
fantastic television that's very long
form but certainly for a film like this
that at its heart is a romance and I
thought it should really be centered on
these two amazing characters in these
two clashing worlds and as amazing as
those worlds are when you stretch it out
over TV it could be that Aisha and Luke
got a bit lost and I felt like really
focusing on the love was what the film
and the story needed to be about out
ultimately great success in that respect
I want to know a little bit about your
Dynamic when directing so obviously you
two know each other very well is there
anything about your collaboration as
co-directors that came as a surprise
once you actually were on the ground on
set making the film uh yeah I think we
expected it to be more difficult really
because we both have opinions you know
we both are kind of comfortable in our
work and we feel we know what we want
now in our careers
um but actually you know very rarely did
we disagree and when we had tiny little
disagreements which were inevitable in a
creative process I think we always made
the right decision for the film yeah
um and it was great it was a dream and
look on this film it's like a lot of
independent films I think you know you
have a bit more creative control and
breathing space which I think helps you
know in this kind of situation but also
we have a shorthand you know like we
know each other so well in life we've
worked together before on two films so
you know with a look we could almost
kind of go yeah we've we've got that
take or we want to do we like this so no
we need to do that again and when time
was sure it was very helpful because
we'd be like split the work so you go
speak to that person I'll speak to this
person we could do double in half the
time so it was really practical I
believe just like how perfect this whole
operation seems but yeah I mean you
should have something else yeah I will
throw it to the two of you next what is
something about working with
co-directors that you think served your
performance the best maybe even helped
you exceed your own expectations for
your work of the roles I think what made
it so special is the actual relationship
that you guys had because like you say
like any kind of small conflicts were
resolved within seconds you know so it
was it could have gone terribly wrong if
you had two people clashing heads the
whole time but in fact what it turned
out to be was just two wonderful
creative minds helping guide me and
Jason through the process so it it was
just another strength really yeah and
like you say like when they have like
different opinions it kind of gives you
like multiple perspectives and so it
makes you kind of think about oh okay
maybe I didn't spring that actually to
this scene or this moment you know
and what's good is that like because
like they have that report in that
relationship that they're both so
passionate about it and that you have
you've had both you've both been in it
for like seven years like basically so
you're they're so determined to like
make this the best film possible and so
it inspired us because we obviously want
to make the best film possible I don't
know how clearly you remember the
specifics but can you maybe give me an
example of a time when they brought
different perspectives to a scene and it
wound up enhancing the scene because you
got to Envision two different paths for
the characters
I was gonna say I was gonna say when we
were like really stretched for time and
we had to do the the fight scene oh yeah
and that
and I remember Sally and James that's
that's the time when they literally had
to split the work and they're like right
we're gonna have to change all of this
cut this cut this let's do this let's go
straight to that and we were like okay
we've got one take let's go
I remember there was one scene actually
where you you return and see him outside
the garage the first time you come to
the garage yeah and I remember like uh
you were doing your speech about the
madra and all that kind of stuff I
remember you got one piece of direction
from Sally that was one way yeah and
you've got another piece of situation
for me that was almost the opposite and
what was nice was that it gave us two
options and I remember the third take
that you did was kind of like
half of each which was almost different
of itself yeah so it gave it gave us
different colors you know which was
really important yeah I have to come
back to you Jason because I said it to
you before you sat down how is this your
first lead role in a major feature film
I don't quite understand that I want our
audience to learn more about you and I
know music is a high priority for you so
did you always Envision yourself
becoming a musician or did acting and
that dream exist side by side since the
start yeah they both existed side by
side I've I think I'm just a creative
person in general and so it's kind of
like you know what is the best medium
for
what I want to say like sometimes music
is the best medium for something that I
specifically want to say and what was
really great about this was that it's
not necessarily my baby this is their
baby and but I'm so happy to be a part
of this like project and collaborate on
it too I remember you saying to us that
you felt that um you've been preparing
for this show all your life my whole
life yeah I could do that something that
I can just literally like get my teeth
into and give everything that I got and
I told them I was like listen guys I
sing I songwrite I play these
instruments like use it like you know to
your advantage and we and you did didn't
yeah yeah which is great so so you come
into the project with all these
different skills you're gonna go on to
lead more films I just know in the
future what is a particular lesson
learned or a skill you gain making
unicorns that you're eager to apply to
another movie Down the Line oh
um
patience
I'm someone that honestly like just is
like go go go go go
so sometimes you just need to like stop
listen and just
Let It Go and
I forget I can and also I don't know
like in general just from this process
these three people
just made me like a better human a
better performer like a better creative
and I'm not just saying that because I'm
sat here on camera and I have to say
that but it's genuinely like how I feel
like I literally owe my life to them
sometimes that's how I feel okay I'll go
down that path and pose a question to
you and you as well Ben because I love
talking about the value of a good scene
partner especially when I see such
electrochemistry in the finished film so
can each of you tell me something about
the other that you appreciated as a
scene partner and maybe helped you
access something in your own character
that you wouldn't have been able to
without without them I mean Jason is
just a very generous person in in
general and that really comes across in
his work as well you know so he was
always trying to facilitate and help me
in scenes just as I was trying to help
him so really I suppose it was that just
a very generous actor which is not I'm
not saying it's not uh completely rare
but sometimes you don't find that and um
yeah it really helped us made the best
of this I think what's really just
balancing off what you said like we just
was there to like support each each
other and we do that throughout like
after this process as well like we're
such good friends and we just we just
cared about like what we were doing and
I could tell that this person is just
passionate about what they do just as
much as I am which is great because not
ever you don't always get to work with
people like that like you said so like
in this process I was like yeah I've
just kind of found like someone who's
like my match in that sense we had
little pep talks as well
let's just do this let's go you guys are
saying all the right keywords for a
company to just Excel like generosity
patience passion my God you were so so
good to me when this is sometimes early
on in the film when Luke is very
resistant to uh Aisha you know within
his mind I would be quite horrible to
you wouldn't I before too but what do
you mean and he would he would scream
when black and like yeah go for it yeah
yeah so and you were wonderfully
accepting of that and let me letting me
do that to get where I needed to be so
thank you yeah yeah and it worked out
yeah you're welcome man I'll come your
way with a specific question about your
filmography because I've seen a good
deal of your work I haven't seen all of
it so I might be missing something that
aligns with this but this is probably
like one of the like warmest most
sincere grounded projects I've seen you
do so given that kind of material is
there anything that's changed about how
you prepare to play a role or maybe any
new acting techniques that that you had
to use on set in order to make the most
of that kind of material
um I mean I think I've been knocking
around for for a little while so I've
kind of you know my craft is always kind
of chopping and changing but kind of you
know evolving I hope anyway but I
suppose working with uh with James and
Sally was and I've said this before and
I'll say it again it was the most
rewarding creative process I've
experienced I'm very thankful for that
and two of like the hardest working
people I've ever come across so we would
be on zooms till midnight and Beyond
we'd be around their house they would
offer to let us stay around their house
I know you know it was so in-depth you
know it was just it was incred so when
it came to the first day of filming I've
never felt so prepared for a role in my
life because I felt like we had done so
many page turns of the script I'm
actually getting emotional anyway well
yeah yeah
of the script and uh you know we've just
gone through every single beat so it
just felt I felt so prepared So yeah
thank you what about not overthinking
to be like be in the now
Luke's in the now you have to be in the
now yeah it just sounds like this whole
group is an extension of your family I'm
like I'm a big believer that a cast and
crew should feel feel like a family just
because you have to give so much of
yourself to make a movie so that is kind
of like the ideal atmosphere there
bringing bringing that up the prep and
maybe some work shopping too can you all
give me an example of a particular scene
that was most challenging and demanded
the most workshopping in order to find
the pitch perfect way to play it I think
it has to be the last scene of the movie
we um had so many versions and we
discussed it so much and even to the
point where we went into it not
convinced of ever what was written as
the last scene of the movie in the
script and we all didn't know how things
should end in that last scene and we
were fighting against
um I guess I don't want to give spoilers
but we were fighting against a certain
conventional way
um that that scene could have played out
and so we shot so many versions of it
and even into the edit we cut so many
versions and we tried the movie with so
many different resolutions and endings
and we feel we really landed on the one
that ironically
we all kind of in the moment felt was
right but second guessed ourselves and
and overthought it and thought maybe
it's not but um we did actually end up
with that one I think that is the right
one that's on the film oh I love hearing
about how things love I want to know
about the other endings and the way you
Workshop that we'll talk about it after
though
um I'll throw this question to the two
of you to start but anyone feel free to
jump in I love seeing movies that
introduce people to new communities in
particular here the Asian community so
is there any single aspect of that
community that you are most excited to
bring to screen in this film maybe a
film that will have someone out there
experience or learn about it for the
very first time yeah that's a really
good question I mean I'm tempted to say
all of it but I think for me personally
I think the family aspect I think very
very rarely do we see
um queer South Asians interact with
their family in such a complex way you
see the love you see the hate you see
the darkness you see the light you see
all of that sometimes in in one scene
and I think in particular I think the
relationship between the mother and
ashik is something that is is very very
close to me because my mum is Indian and
we have a very interesting kind of
complex relationship and you know we
just don't see that that much in on film
so for me I'm very proud of the fact
that I think Asians get to have the
complexity of their family relationships
I think put into this one rather than
their chosen family which is often kind
of How It's presented as
um that's all that exists in their lives
is the chosen family as opposed to the
born
want to add anything before I move on I
got two more I want to squeeze it all
right well for first James because you
were just talking about some of those
elements I was reading your director's
statement and I know you had mentioned
you were very excited to share this film
with the world but you were nervous
about sharing it with your family and I
hope it's not too personal if you don't
want to answer it don't but I was
wondering has your family seen the film
and if so what are they no I mean like
you know so I have some family of mind
inside that you know quite religious and
they're actually Christians
um so I'm sure they will have some
interesting opinions on the film
um but I think you know that's the whole
point of of if you can call film an art
form you know like I think that's the
whole point of art is that you've got to
go deep into yourself and and you have
to be you know naked sometimes literally
uh but it's it's I think it's something
that you know you've got to Bear your
soul otherwise um I always feel like a
camera is like a lie detector you know
like if if you're not telling the truth
some way whether it be as a filmmaker or
as an actor I think it can tell and I
think that's where you've just got to be
like you know screw it this is me this
is how I feel and and a bit like what
happens to the two characters you've got
to take that leap of faith and just you
know jump off the cliff and it is is
frightening but I think I'm at a point
in my life where I'm like you know what
if I had it my way I'd only do films
like this that a very personal and true
to me doing films are things that scare
you will wind up making tackling those
challenges easier for someone else out
there so I appreciate being able to do
something like that for all four of you
now this is one of my favorite questions
to end on so I find that a lot of people
in this industry have a very tough time
telling themselves good job we give each
other rewards and say good job to each
other all the time but I want to know
something you accomplish on this film
that you know you'll be able to look
back on and say to yourself like damn I
am proud of what I did there you've come
to the right crowd here because
[Applause]
wake up in the morning look at ourselves
in the mirror and go we are amazing
oh my God I look so good well done to me
teach me your secrets please
for me I actually found that just you
know it's affirmation really it's just
you know I just have said that to myself
so many times that I believe it that
hubris is now my problem yeah but yeah
yeah no I'm very being serious I am very
proud of this movie so
um you know and I think I can accept
that um you know uh and acknowledge that
and so that's a wonderful thing as you
should
yeah
no no I I I've forgotten the question
but I just you sort of maybe think about
how that's a really I never thought of
that and I thought that's really smart
it's like you're right like I think it's
it's important to say to yourself in
this industry that is so uncertain and I
think in particular in the times that we
live in now
you know like we're we're very very
lucky that we're here because you know
we are an independent film we are
outside the jurisdiction of sag and wga
but this is an industry that is full of
unemployment
even when there isn't a strike so for me
you know it just you got me thinking of
gratitude and just this idea of saying
yeah you know what like we are good and
we've made a good movie and um we're
very very lucky to have this at a film
festival during this time and um yeah it
makes me very sad what's happening in
our industry if I'm totally honest you
know it makes you quite angry but it's a
necessary battle that we've all got to
fight
um yeah anyway absolutely
does anyone else want to add anything
before I have to let you go me and Sally
know we were great
thanks
sincerely you are all great you deserve
all the celebration that's coming for
this movie huge congratulations on
unicorns and to everybody out there
watching do not miss it keep an eye out
for this film and we will see you soon
at the cinema center at marble for more
interviews from Tiff 2023